guys I have a huge announcement this is
the longest I've been single since I was
fifteen fifty Thank You small crowd of
children for the last seven months I've
been working on myself working out and
working working working working as a
therapy and now that my heart has
scraped itself off the floor and
stitched it's broken bloody mangled body
together and cleaned herself up I'm
ready to get back out there and I have
never been someone who like goes on
dates I almost always meet a person
through work or mutual friends and then
we like each other and then I'm so
navigating the dating scene has been
awkward for example the first date I
went on when like this
I like watched all your videos like you
know figure out what you're all about
and I feel like I know so much more
about your life than you know about my
life oh so tell me your life story I'm
boring okay but I do have two cats oh
okay cool you know look what the fuck is
up with vegan places so they're always
trying to make like baked versions of
like real food
[Music]
so what do you do for a living oh I work
for a tech company well that's cool do
you like it no I fucking hate it but
I've been there for like eight years
okay and then I had to sit for another
half hour and talk to this gentleman but
I'm learning how to be comfortable
saying no not only because I don't want
to waste anyone elses time but I also
don't want to hurt their feelings you
know by being dishonest or by ghosting
oh I guess the can have sex now someone
that the real transparent being well
haven't you seen the movie Ghost
[Music]
oh he what would I die so I've started
being totally upfront about how I feel
Who I am and what I'm looking for
and if someone can't meet those
expectations no hard feelings and I know
dating can be confusing and difficult
but if you navigate it by knowing what
you want and are kind and respectful of
people's feelings and your own most
importantly it is an infinitely better
process and yes dating so far has been a
literal nightmare but as me and my
friends have liked to say I'm Anna Akana
stay right here for an animated message
from Squarespace thank you to
Squarespace for sponsoring today's video
Squarespace is single beautiful and has
award-winning templates Plus that baby
is an all-in-one platform so there's no
need to install patches or upgrades ever
they have 24-hour customer service if
you want to send a text at 3 a.m. and a
simple and unique domain setup
experience if you need to register your
site with all your red flags with
Squarespace you can create any kind of
website whether you're a matchmaker a
serial dater or you just want to make a
page where you blog about the turmoils
of your dating life go to
squarespace.com sachi Anna to start your
free trial today and use the offer code
Anna for 10% off that check
[Music]